สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
พฤษภาคมเดือนนี้เดือนอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันจันทร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนพฤษภาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 24
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนพฤษภาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
2 ทุ่ม
2 ทุ่มกี่นาที 20
นาทีค่ะ
2 ทุ่ม 3 นาทีก็เป็นเวลากลางคืนแล้วอะไร
คะเวลาที่อเมริกากี่โมงคะ
เวลาที่อเมริกา
9 โมง 3 นาทีค่ะตอนเช้าค่ะครูฟ้า
แต่วันเดียวกันนะวันนี้ก็วันอังคาร
และเวลาที่ออสเตรเลียก็
5 ทุ่ม
ใช่อันนี้เวลาที่ประเทศไทย
[เพลง]
ในเวลา
23 นาที
[เพลง]
เสร็จแล้วใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะเสร็จแล้วค่ะครูฟ้าทำงานเสร็จ
แล้ว
ก็อาจจะไปทำงานที่นี้เป็น
ร้านอาหารใช่ไหมขายอาหารไทยแล้วก็ตอนนี้
ครูฟ้าอยู่ที่บ้านแล้วเวลาครูฟ้าทำงานที่
ร้านอาหารเนี่ยแล้วก็มีคนใช่ไหมอาจจะมีคน
ออสเตรเลียคนไทย
ไปเที่ยวร้านแล้วก็ไปกินอาหารไทยเขาจะ
สั่งเมนูอะไรมากๆค่ะ
แกงเขียว
ใช่กรีนเคอรี่เรดเคอรี่อันนี้เมนูภาษา
อังกฤษ
[เพลง]
อันนี้อันนี้ไม่ใช่ผัดไทยร้านทุเรียนอัน
นี้
มัสมั่น
เป็นเหมือนซุป
ผัดไทยเข้าใจได้นะคะว่าอ๋อคนต่างชาติใช่
ไหมคนที่
ไม่ใช่คนไทยอ่ะพี่ชอบกิน
ก็จะสั่งผัดไทย
ผัดซีอิ๊ว
ก็เยอะ
แต่ถ้าเป็นคนไทยเวลาสมมุติถ้าอย่างครู
หญิงอยู่อเมริกาใช่ไหมคะอยู่อเมริกามา
เนี่ย
ประมาณประมาณ
3 อาทิตย์
คิดว่าอยู่มา 3 อาทิตย์บวกๆ
ก็คิดถึงอาหารไทยแล้วแบบอยากกินอาหารไทย
เมื่อวานเมื่อวานวันจันทร์ใช่ไหมคะ 23
กินอาหารไทยมาค่ะ
ครูหญิงกินอาหารไทยในอเมริกาเหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าเบื่อแฮมเบอร์เกอร์เบื่อ
แฮมเบอร์เกอร์
รู้แล้วว่าเบื่อแฮมเบอร์เกอร์ก็เลยกิน
อาหารในอเมริกา
ใช่แล้วแบบอยากกินอาหารไทยเมนูนี้มากๆเลย
ครูฟ้า
ครูหญิงกินอะไรๆ
อันนี้ก็คือ
[เพลง]
ขอโทษนะคะพูดภาษาไทยได้ไหม
ส้มตำ
เออใช่ส้มตำ
ส้มตำไทย
ที่ครูฟ้าทำงาน
เมนูส้มตำเนี่ยเขาเขียนเป็นภาษาอังกฤษว่า
ส้ม
ตำ
ไหมคะหรือว่า
เอิ่มส้มตำมีเมนูอยู่นะว่าจำไม่ผิดก็ใช่
ค่ะส้มตำ
ได้คำว่าส้มตำแบบนี้เลยหรอคะไหนส้มตำมีคำ
ว่าปาปาย่าสลัดด้วยขออนุญาตสลัดอะไรอย่าง
นี้แต่ว่าส่วนใหญ่เป็นส้มตำไทยสไตล์อะไร
ประมาณนี้อะไรแบบนี้
เขาเขาไม่ได้เขียนว่าส้มตำเขาก็เขียน
ภาพยนตร์
[เพลง]
จะมี
บางร้านมั้งก็เลยอยากรู้ไงก็เลยถามครูฟ้า
ว่าร้านอาหารไทยที่ออสเตรเลียที่ครูฟ้า
เนี่ยทำงานเขียนว่าส้มตำหรือว่าพระพาย่า
สลัดสมัยท่านนักเรียนไม่อยู่ประเทศไทย
แล้วก็ดูดูวีดีโอนี้แล้วเห็นเมนูนี้อาจจะ
อยากกินจะได้รู้ว่าเวลาไปร้านอาหารไทย
เนี่ยจะสั่งว่าอะไร
ซึ่งเป็นนักเรียน
ส้มตำส้มตำ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบกินส้มตำไหมคะ
ชอบมาก
ประเทศไทยไปกินส้มตำมากค่ะ
แล้วร้านอาหารไทยที่ครูฟ้าทำงานเนี่ยมี
เมนูส้มตำไหม
ร้านอาหารไทยที่คุณฟ้าทำงานมีสิคะเมนูส้ม
ตำเห็นว่าส้มตำเลย
[เพลง]
ยังไม่เคยกินส้มตำที่นี่เลยนะ
แต่อันนี้คือ
อันนี้ที่อเมริกาหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะ
อันนี้
ถ้านักเรียนมาประเทศไทยนักเรียนก็จะได้
กินส้มตำแบบนี้แต่ถ้านักเรียนอยู่ต่าง
ประเทศแล้วไปร้านอาหารไทยมันก็จะ
ของครูฟ้าเนี่ยมันอะไรอ่ะ
มันเหมือนอันนี้เลยนะคะเพราะว่าส้มตำที่
ออสเตรเลีย
ที่ครูฟ้าในร้านอาหารของครูฟ้าเป็นแบบนี้
เลย same เหมือนกัน
เหมือนกันเลย
แล้วก็ครูฟ้าก็ชอบกินส้มตำครูหญิงก็ชอบคน
ไทยหลายๆคนเนี่ยก็ชอบกินส้มตำแต่ส้ม
ตำเนี่ยมันจะมีพริกอย่างส้มตำที่คุณหญิง
กินเมื่อวานนะคะคุยบอกว่าเอาเขาจะมีเผ็ด
แบบเผ็ดมากๆ
เผ็ดกลางแล้วก็เผ็ดนิดหน่อยอาจจะเผ็ด
เลเวล
เสร็จเลเวล 2 เผ็ด Level  3 เพราะว่ามัน
มีพริก
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยสั่ง
เผ็ด
2 เผ็ดกลาง
แต่ส้มตำที่ผู้หญิงกินเมื่อวานนี้คือเผ็ด
นะเผ็ดมากนี่คือเผ็ดแบบกลางหรอ
สั่งเผ็ดกลางก็เผ็ด
ทำไมเผ็ดเลเวล 2 ถึงเผ็ดมากล่ะคะคุณหญิง
ผู้หญิงอาจจะ
กินเผ็ดไม่ได้กินเผ็ดเท่าภูฟ้าเนาะครูฟ้า
จะกินเผ็ดมากกว่าคุณแต่สำหรับผู้หญิงก็
แบบเผ็ด 2 เผ็ดกลางก็เผ็ดแล้ว
แล้วถ้านักเรียนน่ะนักเรียนไม่ใช่คนไทย
ใช่ไหมคะนักเรียนเนี่ยอาจจะกินพริก
ไม่ได้กินเผ็ด
หรือคนไทยบางคนก็ไม่ได้กินเผ็ดมากๆเวลา
กินส้มตำเนี่ยมันเผ็ดผู้หญิงเนี่ยจะชอบ
กินส้มตำเนี่ยคู่กับโค้กเวลาสั่งส้มตำก็
จะเอาโค้ก 1 ขวดค่ะ
โค้กทำให้เราเผ็ดไหม
จริงๆเราเผ็ดนะ
คงทำให้เราเผ็ดนะคะนักเรียนกินส้มตำเผ็ด
ดื่มโค้กเผ็ดๆ
มากๆ
ใช่แต่ผู้หญิงอร่อย
คู่กับโค้กอันนี้ที่เป็นเครื่องดื่ม
เครื่องดื่ม
ใช่คือคนไทยก็กินส้มตำกับโค้กนั่นแหละใช่
ไหมว่าร้านอาหารที่ขายส้มตำมันก็จะมีโค้ก
ด้วย
ปกติจะเป็นโค้ก
แต่ว่าจริงๆแล้วเนี่ยเวลาที่นักเรียนมามา
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยมันจะส้มตำเนี่ยมันก็จะ
อยู่ในร้านส้มตำเลย
ถ้าอย่างร้านอาหารไทยที่ขายผัดไทยผัด
ซีอิ๊วหรือว่าพวกแกงเชยพวก kerry แกง
มัสมั่นเนี่ย
ถ้าที่ไทยเนี่ยก็จะไม่มีส้มตำขายนะมันจะ
แย่
ร้านอาหาร
แล้วก็ร้านส้มตำ
ใช่ค่ะปกติประเทศไทยร้านส้มตำก็คือร้าน
ส้มตำนะคะนักเรียนแล้วเมนูในร้านส้มตำก็
ไม่เหมือนร้านอาหาร
อื่นๆ
เมนูในร้านส้มตำก็จะมีส้มตำเยอะๆใช่ไหม
แล้วก็มี
สไตล์เผ็ดๆอ่ะ
ใช่แล้วเวลาที่เราไปร้านส้มตำเราแบบอยาก
กินส้มตำอย่างนี้เราก็จะไม่สั่งส้มตำ
อย่างเดียวแล้วก็จะสั่งอาหารที่เอามากิน
กับส้มตำด้วย
อาหารไทย
[เพลง]
ค่ะสมัยคนไทยเนี่ยก็จะมีที่ต้องกินคู่กัน
เลยคือถ้าสั่งส้มตำปุ๊บก็ต้องสั่งอันนี้
ด้วย
อะไรคะ
ข้าวเหนียวค่ะครูฟ้า
ข้าวเหนียว
ใช่
เดี๋ยวคุยเอารูปมาขึ้นให้นะ
คะเดี๋ยวคุยทีหลัง
ทำงานเนี่ยมีส้มตำ
และข้าวเหนียวนะคะ
เป็นคนออสเตรเลียคนต่างชาติแล้วเวลาเขา
สั่งส้มตำเนี่ยเขาสั่งข้าวเหนียวมากินกับ
ส้มตำไหมคะ
ไม่คือคนไม่รู้ไงว่าส้มตำกินกับข้าว
เหนียวส่วนใหญ่ก็จะสั่งข้าวฟายไว้สั่ง
มัสมั่นแล้วก็สั่งส้มตำ
เวลาคนไทยในร้านอาหารไทยที่ต่างประเทศ
แล้วก็เห็นมัสมั่น
ส้มตำ
เป็นอย่างนี้แหละเพราะว่าคนไม่รู้ใช่ไหม
มีแต่คนไทยไงรู้ว่ากินยังไง
จะให้คนไทยแหละก็ส้มตำข้าวเหนียวแล้วก็
ต้องมีอีกอย่างนึงที่จะแบบว่าต้องเป็น
Package อยู่ด้วยกันเลยข้าวเหนียวส้มตำ
แล้วก็อย่างหนึ่งครูฟ้าคิดว่าอะไรที่เรา
จะเอามากินกับส้มตำ
ข้าวเหนียวส้มตำ
คอหมูย่าง
ไก่ย่างหรอ
เฮ้ย
มันคู่กันนะครูฟ้าข้าวเหนียวส้มตำไก่ย่าง
เวลาที่เราไปร้านส้มตำที่เป็นแบบ Street
Food อ่ะที่เขาจะขายเป็นรถเข็นนะคะเป็น
รถเข็นขายส้มตำเนี่ยเขาก็จะมีส้มตำใช่ไหม
แล้วก็จะมีข้าวเหนียวแล้วเขาก็จะย่างไก่
เขาก็จะมีไก่ย่างด้วยกินด้วยกันเพราะส้ม
ตำมันก็เผ็ดอ่ะ
[เพลง]
แต่กินกับไข่แต่กินกับไก่ย่างเนี่ยมันก็
จะอร่อยมากขึ้นไง
[เพลง]
แต่ถ้านักเรียนอยู่ต่างประเทศอย่างร้าน
อาหารไทยในออสเตรเลียอย่างนี้ก็อาจจะไม่
มีไก่ย่าง
แต่ถ้านักเรียนมาประเทศไทย
นักเรียนมาประเทศไทยแล้วอยากกินส้มตำที่
ไทยก็สั่งเลยค่ะชอบเหนียวส้มตำไก่ย่างแต่
บางครั้งเนี่ยเราก็ไม่ชอบกินข้าวเหนียวไง
คืออย่างคุยหญิงผู้หญิงก็ชอบกินข้าว
เหนียวนะแต่ข้าวเหนียวอ่ะบางทีเรากินมากๆ
เนี่ยมันอิ่มอิ่ม
ง่วงนอน
ให้ค่ะข้าวเหนียวมันทำไมข้าวเหนียวกิน
แล้วอิ่ม
กินข้าว
กิน
ขนมปังก็อิ่ม
แต่ข้าวเหนียวเนี่ยอิ่มมากนะคะ
ใช่ค่ะ
เพราะว่าบางครั้งเนี่ยนักเรียนก็จะเห็น
ว่าคนไทยสั่งส้มตำสั่งข้าวเหนียวสั่งไก่
ย่างแล้วเราก็ยังสั่งอีกอย่างนึงที่มากิน
กับส้มตำที่ไม่ใช่ข้าวแล้วก็ไม่ใช่ข้าว
เหนียว
ขนมจีนค่ะ
วันนี้กินขนมจีนมาค่ะ
กินกับอะไรไม่ได้กินกับส้มตำใช่ไหม
ไม่ใช่ส้มตำกินกับคลีนี่แหละเป็นแกงนะคะ
คือจริงๆแล้วส่วนใหญ่แล้วเนี่ยขนมจีน
เนี่ยเราจะกินคู่กับพวกแกง
มัสมั่นก็กินได้หรอแกงเขียวหวานอย่างนี้
แกงเขียวหวานกินกับขนมจีนได้แต่ขนมจีนก็
เอามากินกับส้มตำได้อร่อยเหมือนกัน
บางคนอาจจะไม่ชอบกินข้าวเหนียวส้มตำก็
สั่งขนมจีนมากินคู่กับส้มตำขนมจีนมันก็จะ
เป็นเส้นๆใช่
[เพลง]
ค่ะ
ส้มตำส้มตำก็เป็นเส้น
ส้มตำมันเป็นเส้นมะละกอไง
เส้นก๋วยเตี๋ยวก็เอามากินกับส้มตำได้ก็มี
[เพลง]
Amazing ไหมใช่ค่ะจริงๆแล้วเราอยากกิน
อะไรกับส้มตำก็ได้แต่ที่เราสองคนมาคุยให้
ฟังในวีดีโอนี้เนี่ยส่วนใหญ่มันเป็นสิ่ง
ที่คนไทยหลายๆคนเนี่ยสั่งมากินกับส้ม
ข้าวเนี๊ยบ
ขนมจีนหรือว่าแคบหมู
ครูฟ้าก็มี
นักเรียนครูฟ้าอยู่ออสเตรเลียเหมือนอยู่
ไทยเลยนะคะว่ามีทุเรียนมีแคบหมู
มีข้าวเหนียวมีขนมจีน
ใช่แคบหมูเลยนะคะมันก็ทำมาจากหมูอ่ะหมู
ใช่ไหมอันนี้หมู
หมูก็จะมีไหล่อันนี้ก็เป็นหลักนะแคปหมู
เนี่ย
แล้วก็มีกระทะ
ใส่น้ำมันแล้วก็
เอาไปทอดใช่ไหมเอาหนังหมูไปทอดแล้วเวลา
กินเนี่ยมันจะ
กรอบๆมันก็อร่อยนะเหมือนเรากินส้มตำ 1 คำ
จริงๆส้มตำใช้มือกินก็ได้นะคะ
ประเทศไทยอาจจะเห็นคนไทยใช้มือกินแต่ก็
น้อยนะคะส่วนใหญ่แล้วก็จะใช้เนี่ยแหละ
ซ่อม
แล้วก็หยิบแคบหมูมากินกรอบๆอร่อย
อร่อยมากค่ะนักเรียนพูดแล้วครูฟ้าอยากกิน
ส้มตำกับแคบหมูเลยนะคะ
ใช่แล้วแต่ถ้าเป็นตัวครูฟ้าเองอ่ะครูฟ้า
ชอบกินส้มตำคู่กับอะไรมากที่สุด
คอหมูย่าง
หมูอีกแล้วนะคะ
เปิดให้ดูได้นะคะผู้หญิง
ได้หรอ
ส้มตำกับคอหมูย่างมากที่สุดใช่ไหมคะคือคอ
หมูย่างมันก็ความรู้สึกคล้ายๆไก่ย่างอ่ะ
เนาะบางคนชอบกินส้มตำไก่ย่างแต่ว่าครูฟ้า
ชอบกินส้มตำกับคอหมูย่าง
ใช่ค่ะอร่อยมากค่ะฟ้าชอบกินคอหมูย่างมากๆ
แล้วครูฟ้าก็ชอบกินส้มตำก็เลย
พอกินคอหมูย่าง
อร่อยมาก
อิ่มเลยหลับกินเสร็จหลับเลยนะคะแล้วนัก
เรียนล่ะถ้านักเรียนอยู่ประเทศไทยเคยกิน
ส้มตำนักเรียนเนี่ยชอบกินส้มตำคู่กับอะไร
มากๆ
คอมเมนต์บอกเราได้นะคะส่วนวีดีโอนี้แหละ
เราสองไปก่อนแล้วว่าหิวแล้วนะเดี๋ยวเรามา
เจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะ
[เพลง]